foreign
[Music]
amazon.com and you remember this started
as a bookstore an online bookstore it's
the biggest bookstore in the world they
have everything there's nothing you
can't find on Amazon including used
books so if you were to go onto Amazon
to read books by a man who is in the
news and whose ideas are directly
bearing on world events you look for a
guy called Alexander Dugan dugin is one
of Russia's most famous authors and
political philosophers she doesn't work
for the government he doesn't work for
Vladimir Putin he's just a philosopher
so if you're interested in like what are
they thinking over there you would
search dugent's author page on Amazon
but you would not find any results
really kind of a big author to be left
off Amazon so we reach out to Amazon to
ask why can't we find any books by this
guy
and then we realized because he's been
banned from Amazon so then we asked
Amazon for a list of all books and
authors who've been banned from their
platform
and they wouldn't give it to us so we
went back and forth back and forth and
finally Amazon provided a six-word
response and we're quoting Amazon
complies with all applicable laws
hmm applicable laws well in the United
States there are no laws against
publishing books because we have the
First Amendment the government can never
under any circumstances censor any book
period or anything that you have to say
period because that's the core of our
Bill of Rights
then we learned that Amazon and the
justice department were ignoring our
Bill of Rights Amazon apparently based
this decision on a treasury Department
designation concerning quote
disinformation
and that designation applies not only to
digin but also to his family though not
to his daughter who was murdered
recently by the Ukrainian government
we're not allowed to say that would it
cheat you wrong well I guess she said
the wrong thing but that's cool because
they're fighting for freedom but that's
the point the point is in our country
which is very different from Ukraine
we're allowed to read whatever we want
but we can't now because the Biden
Administration is demanding that the
biggest Bookseller in the world censor
books that they disagree with and Amazon
complies without asking any questions
now this is as clear a violation as the
first amendment as you could concoct in
a law school class
so then we reach out to the treasury
Department
did this really happen yeah it did
they essentially confirmed it quote we
don't comment on possible enforcement
matters but the treasury Department
continues to vigorously enforce
russia-related sanctions oh really there
is no legal basis for ever censoring any
book if you're the US government that is
not allowed that's the main thing that's
not allowed in this country period we
don't care who wrote the book you're
allowed to read it you can read any book
you want you're an American
and if you cease to be able to read any
book you want it doesn't matter if
you're an American because you're just a
surf
well Amazon has refused to provide us
with a list of the other books they are
Banning but they clearly are Banning a
lot of different books and why can't we
know what those books are we're going to
continue to look into this and if there
are any legal challenges to the book
Banning which is one click from book
burning
we hope there are legal challenges we'll
let you know about those as well
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight